خلال الأسبوع الماضي ، تم فحص أكثر من 7.1 مليون
شخص عند نقاط التفتيش التابعة لـ TSA
على الرغم من
تحذيرات مركز السيطرة على الأمراض للبقاء في المنزل
لقضاء العطلات
التي قد ندخلها في فبراير مع
استمرار تأثير أحداث عيد الميلاد
علينا حتى مع ظهور هذا
اللقاح
الآن ، تحول القلق نحو جديد
تقول CDC إن الطريقة الأكثر أمانًا للاحتفال
هي في المنزل مع الأشخاص الذين تعيش معهم أو
مع الأصدقاء والعائلة تقريبًا ،
وتقول الوكالة إن السفر والتجمعات
مع أولئك الذين لا يعيشون معك
يمكن أن يزيد من فرص الإصابة
بفيروس كوفيد 19 أو الأنفلونزا وانتشارها
إذا كنت تستضيف احتفالًا أو تذهب إلى
محادثة واحدة قبل التجمع لتحديد
التوقعات ، أبقِ الاحتفالات في الهواء الطلق
إن أمكن إذا كان ذلك ممكنًا
إذا كانت النوافذ والأبواب المفتوحة بالداخل نظيفة
وطهر الأسطح الملموسة بشكل متكرر ، اطلب من
الضيوف إحضار أطباق الطعام الخاصة بهم
وأطباق المشروبات والأواني تحافظ على مستوى
صوت الموسيقى في الخلفية
منخفضًا  لا يحتاج الضيوف إلى الصراخ الذي قد
يقلل من استخدام الجزيئات المحمولة جواً
خيارات الاستخدام الفردي مثل حزم البهارات
و  حد من عدد الضيوف
يقترح بعض خبراء الصحة
أقل من 10 أشخاص واحصل على اختبار مرغوب فيه
مسبقًا ، يكون
مستوى الحماية
لديك قويًا مثل أضعف رابط لديك ، وإذا كان طولك ضعيفًا ،
فسينتشر الفيروس
في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم i  ماندي جيثر